you know what is nice is that you're
getting to show on curb your enthusiasm
you're getting to show this side of you
where you can be impatient with larry
you can be
you can be uh angry with larry you can
disagree with her you can be
mean to larry and it's appropriate
because larry
deserves it let's face it absolutely
and i think that's your job people talk
about you know
are you playing yourself or a version of
you know you have
you're a function you're not a character
on curb you're a function and your
function is to
drive uh larry into a corner
until he gets so you know tight that he
comes out exploding
yes he comes out more larry more
inappropriate
more whatever so that it's basically the
same when you go out to dinner with him
you know you just first off he's so
generous
with his laughter in real life a lot of
standups aren't that way yeah a lot of
standups are kind of no no
i make the jokes yep kind of thing he
loves you to be funny and loves to laugh
at his
his own expense so you basically even
going out to dinner you try to find ways
new ways of insulting them and making
them laugh
which is pretty much the same thing you
do when you go to work the
uh thing that's weird about larry that i
don't think a lot of people know
is that he'll meet you for dinner but
not not at your house or not at his
house
it has to be at a restaurant yeah do you
know what the reason is for that
yes because he uh doesn't want
to be hemmed in by
uh you know societal norms
which means when you're invited to
dinner you stay through dessert
he gets halfway through if he gets any
kind of
agita he's up and out he wants to be so
he can't do it in a restaurant he can we
went out to dinner
i think it was woody harrelson uh p
fairly and myself and maybe someone else
we're going to meet
larry for dinner we were all together in
the afternoon and it was sounded like
great
fun so we all get there even a little
early
so uh and the maintenance says well mr
uh david is uh seated over there and we
show up and he is literally halfway
through his entree
what he's already ordered because
on a whim he's decided i think i'll have
more fun
if i go uh call this lady friend i know
or something yeah you know well i don't
he's right
you know but nevertheless no qualms
about
totally blowing off any kind of right he
wants to he knows that in a restaurant
he can say
i'm done i'm out yeah i'm gone and he
can do it
10 minutes in throw in his share and be
gone but you can't do that at someone's
house
so he's he's got the whole thing stop
going to people's homes
you know larry's character is someone
who's always saying the wrong
thing on his show you yourself have said
that you're prone to a faux pas
occasionally you had a great word yeah
faux pas
yeah it sounds like a faux pas yeah and
it
it does actually i used to pronounce it
foax pass
and then i realized i someone corrected
me about a year ago
but uh yeah faux pas is a great word and
you seem like someone who if you did if
you made a faux pas was because you were
maybe trying too hard to be nice and
maybe said the wrong thing is that is
that where these come from
yeah it's that whole charming thing you
know um
yeah i uh uh i'm trying to think of the
i've done a couple of them
uh my favorite was pretty much first uh
first several interview interviews i did
for cheers and it was very heady and
exciting
somebody actually asked you a bunch of
questions and
you know appeared to be so interested in
everything you were saying so i was just
full of myself and it was a wonderful
interview
and i was charming and it was around the
same time that dr
uh kevorkian was doing a lot of uh
assisted suicides yeah it was very
controversial it was a big thing in the
news at the time yeah
yeah euthanasia where you help people
pass on um and i i
went through my interview sailed through
and then he said one last question
uh what do you think of euthanasia
and i went what you know i think they're
pretty much
the same world over
and i could just see his eyes
[Laughter]
now i understand everything i need to
know about ted